this is sort of the foundation of how
you create that emotional experience for
the audience or for the readers your
protagonist goes through a series of
experiences that lead to a
transformation everything in the story
must keep changing quite a no-return is
the one moment and it's external to the
character which is a very specific thing
that happens once in the screenplay
clock isn't ticking quite as fast you
think of it as four 15-minute scripts
that each one builds on the last you're
writing 120 page script or you know it's
ten page as a sequence if you're right
if you more like 100 page script it's
eight or nine pages of sequence it's not
deciding what you will write it's
providing a form and a template with
which the writer pours their story into
there's not enough scenes here there's
not enough that it's happening for this
to fill two hours I feel like I've heard
about that before what is this crazy
thing called the hero's journey and
that's what a carpenter would do if he
wanted to make a table he would take a
table apart and see how it was put
together that's what a mechanic would do
if he wanted to build an engine
let me preface it by saying this is what
its sort of built on I mean my
underlying philosophy of all
storytelling whether you're a novelist
or screenwriter movie maker TV writer
whatever it might be is that your
primary goal as a storyteller must be to
elicit emotion you must create an
emotional experience for the audience if
it's a movie or a play or for the reader
if you're a screenwriter and you have to
get get it read so you can get the movie
made or if you're a novelist or whatever
so your primary goal has to be to create
emotion and this is a way to accomplish
that goal these are the this is sort of
the foundation of how you create that
emotional experience for the audience or
for the reader and so these six stages
are the six stages you're going to take
your hero through and also the audience
through as we go from the beginning of
the story to the end so the first of the
six stages what constitutes the first
10% of the story is what I call the set
up that's simply where we introduced the
hero you create an emotional connection
of that character you show her living or
everyday life then there's a turning
point the opportunity something new
happens that takes us into the second
stage that's the next 15 percent of the
movie or the script by the way the
percentages if novelists are watching
this are a little more fluid you don't
have to stick quite as closely but in
scripts there are one or two pages on
either side of these percentages pretty
pretty consistently so the second stage
the second 15 percent of the movie is
what I call a new situation your hero
has now been presented with some event
that takes them somewhere new it might
be geographically new or just some new
circumstance where they have to figure
out what's going on then something
happens at the one-quarter mark at the
end of Act one that is going to move the
character towards a specific visible
goal they are going to then declare and
begin pursuing a specific finish line
that they want to reach by the end of
the story my term for that
the outer motivation for the character
because it's outwardly visible and it's
their desire so it might be to stop a
serial killer it might be to win the
love of the love interest in the movie
whatever now they begin pursuing that so
they go into Act two and the first half
of Act two is stage three that's
progress they formulate a plan and the
plan seems to work and the obstacles
start getting bigger and bigger until
finally at the midpoint of that story
they're going to make a bigger
commitment to the goal up to that point
they sort of have one foot in one foot
out now they're going to reach what I
call the point of no return something's
going to happen that demands of them
that they sort of put both feet in so
they're going to devote everything they
can now to achieving the goal they can't
back up they burn their bridges behind
them so to speak so that moves them into
stage 4 which is complications in higher
stakes because the further end of the
story the character goes the more is at
stake because it the goal becomes more
and more important to them but also the
harder it is to achieve the goal the
outside world is going to start closing
and the bad guys going to discover that
the hero is after him or whatever it
might be so it gets tougher and tougher
and tougher until at the 3/4 mark right
at the end of act 2 the hero is going to
suffer or encounter a major setback
something's going to happen that
destroys seemingly any hope of achieving
the goal the plan is out the window the
worst possible thing that could happen
happens and so in response to that the
hero will do two things first the hero's
going to retreat and try and go back to
the life they were living at the
beginning and give up on the goal but
that doesn't work they're not satisfied
they're not fulfilled or they just can't
give up because somebody's life is at
stake or whatever so then they make one
last all-or-nothing do-or-die final push
and that's the stage 5 which is the
final push it's putting everything on
the line giving every ounce of courage
and energy they have until they reach
the final turning point the fifth
turning point and that's the climax
that's where everything gets resolved
that's where the hero faces the villain
for the last time
or the heroines the love of the love
interest and they decide they're going
to live happily ever after or whatever
that climax might be and then the sixth
stage is what I call the aftermath
because we need to see the new life that
this hero that this character is going
to live having completed this journey
and that's pretty much it it's it's like
a before and after picture starting out
in an everyday life going through this
journey to accomplish this goal and then
in the end seeing how their life has
been transformed because they took this
journey
one of my favorite instructors that I
worked with his name is Ron Mita he
taught a class over in Valencia and he
wrote SWAT and then I think he sold some
stuff he developed robots for blue sky
or something really good guy
very practical great writer very cool
guys amazing for pitching as well and he
had this he was the one that introduced
me to this idea of just twenty four plot
points and and he said just you know
literally just write down 24 just 24
numbers and just put PP plot point plot
by plot point and then break it down
into you know the first acts and then
you know most people say first second
and third but everybody divides it at
the midpoint now it really comes down to
how do you define an act and in
researching when I was working on the
videos I was trying to come up with a
good definition for act and you know I
looked at Robert McKee Truby Trottier a
lot of the greats and I couldn't find a
very clear specific definition of an act
so I you know I'm ridiculously pedantic
so I really tried to come down to this
boil it down to its essence I try to be
as precise as I can with the terms and
definitions like for example inciting
incident that words always that terms
always bothered me
just because technically every single
sequence has an inciting incident has an
incident that's inciting the next
behavior a Snyder will refer to as the
catalyst a catalyst is where you take
two elements and a chemical reaction
that's already going to happen and a
catalyst speeds it up so what you're
saying is that the catalyst is going to
take something that's inevitable and
enhances it that's why I call it the
impetus and impetus is a force that
moves that motivates movement and that's
which is a very specific thing that
happens once in the screenplay
so that and that's you know that's my
terminology that I use I think whatever
metaphor helps people make sense of this
story and Taker these essential elements
that's fine so Ron Mitas approach was
basically put the 24 plot points plot
point six is end of Act one
plot point 12 is a midpoint plot point
18 is your low point and then plot point
I think it was twenty one is your climax
and then after that's falling action
very simple and it's like we would we
would literally just sit there and plot
out a story in an hour and it's it's
super pragmatic so from there it really
came down to trying to understand all
right
if we keep dividing everything in the
midpoint like Pilar for example should
you use act a 2a and 2b and it kept on
begging this question what is an act and
that's the big question and when
everybody said you know there's people
like like Dave and friends Oney he came
to CalArts gave one of my favorite
lectures on story ever and he was like
three act structure there's no such
things ax you just understand story you
get into character and you throw
conflict at them and they pursue their
objectives and don't worry about ax and
that's fine now if that works for you
that's awesome I don't like to me all of
its modular all of it is use it as
assets that help you write and anything
that's holding you back from writing let
it go you know has this kind of to me I
like to understand his things as
thoroughly as I can I learned very
slowly and thoroughly and then let go
whenever the story needs to take its own
direction so the way I look at an act is
essentially defined by strategies so a
character the the first act as a
character has a specific strategy which
is their normal daily life this is the
value systems that they that have gotten
them to this point in life so when the
impetus comes in and throws their life
out of balance they find suddenly that
they have to they start to negotiate it
and try and be like well I don't want to
change my life I don't want to do
anything but the second they cross that
threshold and begin to shift into a new
strategy then they've crossed into a new
act so what I've found every single time
is that act to for example you usually
have a character that's you know trying
something new like Tootsie
you know I watched that as a kid it's so
great public is brilliant so you have
was Michael Dorsey who's dressed as
Dorothy Michaels and he's having success
and everything he's doing is bringing
him more and more success and it looks
like hey this new strategy is working
before that a strategy was I'm gonna be
a difficult actor until no one will work
with him so he hits his breaking point
all right I'm gonna dressed as a woman
and commit completely to the role and
and he sees nothing but success until he
hit the midpoint when everything that
he's doing feels like it's paying off
but ultimately betrays his authenticity
so it's at the midpoint where basically
you feel like you're getting everything
you want and this can come is completely
subjective to the needs of the story
this is just generally how the how the
structure tends to go but when you hit
the midpoint often you're you learn that
you are as far away from your original
objective as you could be thinking that
you're just about to achieve it
generally speaking and that realization
whatever that is the introduction of a
new conflict or something like that
creates a kind of shift in strategy and
usually that strategy is very like
frantic and coping and so all the value
systems that had informed that earlier
strategy of hey everything's gonna work
you hit the midpoint and it's failing
and you just come tumbling down the
mountain till you get down to the low
point because all that the first two
acts are all about setup and then the
second two are all about payoff so
that's second that third what I define
is an act well what is to be but I just
go back three it's easier that way is
really just a strategy of collapsing
down the hill until you get to the low
point so all of those choices are paying
off but for the bad the most important
thing is if you've invested in a
character and you care about what the
character wants you understand what the
character wants and you understand
what's at stake if they don't get it
you're free to do anything you want you
can play with start to throw away
structure altogether as long as you have
that like Sorkin says worshipping at the
altar of intent
conflict is evident yeah she get my
quotes down a little better but it's it
really comes down to understanding the
nature of character every scene has to
have a kind of emotional motivation and
if it's not emotional then we're not
we're going to disengage it's not just
it's not just conflict it should be
conflict that's increasing as we're
going along so I mean you know I see a I
see a lot of television a movie I mean
right now is a great time for writers
there's so much good writing there's so
much really strong writing a lot of it
comes down to pacing a lot of it comes
down to really making sure that the
audience is with the main character and
that their choices are making sense and
that that you care about how this is
going to affect the way they're moving
forward but I think if you're tracking
that and most you know most writers
we're all you know we're delving into
ourselves to try and pull out this
meaning a lot of it like for example
working with with producers most of the
notes that I'll get tend to be kind of
you know just tracking like does it make
sense that this character would do this
at this time you know and it's about
trying to project and project yourself
into the character and understand the
intentions and if that's consistent with
your overall character profile
one of the single most important aspects
of screenwriting any long form narrative
II novel writing to just screenwriting
in particular is change things thus
everything in the story must keep
changing as it flows it got it has to be
different 5-10 minutes from now than
then it what the circumstances were
previously ten minutes ago it has to
keep changing and I I had came to
believe there had to be a pattern of
change and what I discovered was this
this gets a little numeric you know
there but stick with me for this because
it's it's important and I think enormous
ly useful three acts okay and in a
screenplay you've got three acts first
act in Act one I noticed there are six
sequences following one another that I
called I came to call hero gold
sequences here's the definition for a
hero gold sequence a hero gold sequence
is any two to seven page section of your
screenplay in which and through which
your hero or heroine pursues one
short-term goal physical short-term goal
only one as one step toward achieving
the overall story goal right just just
that little piece of it and at the end
of that seven or so you nothing is exact
you know but seven or so pages something
happened or some discovery is made by
this hero that I call fresh news in
other words they turn up something that
was unknown by them and by us by the
audience about what they are doing that
puts an end to that current single goal
and offers up a new short term
physical single goal to be pursued in
the next step and that there are six of
these hero goal sequences six little
individual pursuits of individual
specific goals in the entirety of act
one and what we call this many names for
this plot point one there's the the
first major turning point that kind of
thing
I call it stunning surprise one when
stunning surprise one happens which ends
Act one officially and dramatically ends
Act one and kicks the hero forward
tumbling head-over-heels
into Act two I call it stunning surprise
one because that it should be I believe
the emotional impact on both the hero
and the audience it needs to be
emotional and it needs to be impactful
not abstract that always happens in here
a goal sequence six always and it
continues in the first half of the
second act there are six more hero goal
sequences and hero goal sequence number
twelve always contains the midpoint
sequence that's a separate discussion
the midpoint is a fascinating part of
movies that work and it's it's it's rich
and layered with things that go on
relative to character growth and
relative to the plot being you know
bumped up to the next level and all but
it always happens in number 12 in the
second half of Act two there are six
more wonder of wonders there are six
more hero goal sequences and hero goal
sequence 18 always contains stunning
surprise to not seventeen not nineteen
eighteen in every movie that works for
audiences in other words every hit movie
that you can analyze because it's doing
something right
this is the pattern and then in act 3
it's the only act where it can vary
where the numbers can vary and in act 3
you have between 2 & 5 hero goal
sequences I don't recommend five five is
good movies have been made with five
like as good as it gets which has to be
you know one of my favorite romantic
comedies kind of stuff it has five
here we go sequences in rather extended
act three but the audience is getting
antsy and it's time to get out by then I
I the standard the average of movies
that work is 2121 here with goal
sequences eighteen four acts one and two
and then another three in act three
this is a way I know it sounds kind of
weird and mathematical at this point but
this is a way of quantifying change it
tells you in advance this must happen in
these few pages there it also goes
beyond that I mean people were asking
you well and what specifically happens
in each one of these can you nail that
down in a general way yeah I do that in
the book you know I said well these
things usually happen in here real goal
sequence number four you know that kind
of stuff but that's up for grabs and up
for people to play with but structurally
the bones are these 2223 hero goal
sequences laid out in this exact way and
they don't change
but I think the parts that that cause
people that make people the most curious
have to do with our analysis of a movie
of the week and that when we first wrote
the book there were a lot of movies of
the week in which we talked about the
seven act structure of a television show
and the 7x structure you know there is a
3x structure or two stories all stories
have a three-act structure but in the
Renaissance for example stories had five
acts and that's because they divided the
horrible act to that everyone hates I
call it the Serengeti Plain because it's
you know it's the hardest part of the
writing they divided it into three acts
and now there's a five acts story and
it's easier to write because each act
has some beginning middle and end and
each act can be subdivided into twists
and turns and scenes so television goals
goes even further and makes it seven
acts and that's because of commercials
that have to come after each act etc so
people were curious to see that but when
they saw that that the executives at the
studios actually had a chart some of
them actually took the chart into a
pitch meeting and wrote down jotted down
what you know in the chart what the
writer with the pitch was saying about
what happens in each act and so on so
here's the filled out one I'm based on a
movie that we produced and it shows one
liners of the scenes that occur in each
act and I think people realized that
this was they didn't realize how
mechanical it was and honestly when I
hear that which I do often from writers
when I'm in the Old Lace at least when I
was teaching at university extensions
all over the country I realized that
they didn't have them in hella D to be
writers so maybe given a great example
well mama named Millie Mayer god rest
her soul wonderful wonderful lady was a
client for years came up to me at a
Riverside UC Riverside workshop after
and she goes I didn't want to say
anything in front of the classic I
didn't want people make fun of me but I
took my favorite book The Grapes of
Wrath and I outlined it and
that stupid and I said no you're the
only craftsman in the class I mean
that's what a carpenter would do if he
wanted to make a table he would take a
table apart and see how it was put
together that's what a mechanic would do
if he wanted to build an engine he'd
take an engine apart so that's exactly
what you do and that when they see this
kind of breakdown they understand you
know exactly how the mechanics of it
work and honestly until you get to that
point you're really not ready to be a
professional writer because if you
thought that writing was a magic you
know magic trick that you have to pull
off every time or a miracle which I
guess most writers probably would think
a miracle rather than magic trick then
it's impossible right but it's not
possible I mean unassign impossible it's
possible to be a writer
people have been writers for centuries
they've been storytellers and and
storytellers tell stories in parts and
they know what the parts are and they do
them in a way that makes sense and so
the sooner you get down to the mechanics
of how it works the better and that's
what we try to do when our books is to
show people the mechanics I'm looking
through for another there's another page
in here where we show what we call an
intensity chart where you kind of type
one-liners of your whole story on it on
a single piece of paper one-liners of
all the important scenes in the story
then you go between the lines and let's
say you put hyphens two hyphens for a
non dramatic scene or a scene with
relatively little drama and like five
hyphens for a scene with much more drama
and ten hyphens with maximum drama right
so now you've got a page that has all
these hyphens on it underneath the
sentences right then you draw a line
across the hyphens connecting the
hyphens and then you turn it on its side
you turn the piece of paper on its side
in which you've got is something that
looks like a rollercoaster and because
it shows you the ups and downs and your
story's based on the drama the intensity
of the drama in your stories
and that is a great diagnostic tool
because if you see that there's a whole
slope that in which the thing keeps
going down down down and doesn't go up
for a while or it levels off then you
know you need to work on that part of
your story so that's what I call the
mechanical approach you know what I mean
by mechanics like when you when you want
it outline a screenplay or a book you
just use three three by five cards and
you put on those three by five cards the
obligatory scenes in the book and you
won't fill up a whole card because it'll
just be a couple of words on each card
and what you understand when you start
doing that is that creation of the
literary work is what araceli called an
imitation of reality it's not reality
you're not rebuilding the cider house
and the world around the cider house
you're faking it you're making the
reader believe it's there and you do
that mechanically by like I would if I
were making the movie I build a house
front that looks like this outer cider
house right but it wouldn't have a back
because I'm only gonna shoot the front
of it so that's what you're doing when
you're writing your you're just doing
what's necessary to create the illusion
that you're trying to create and the
audience believes that the lusion is
real because it wants to believe that
and you've given them enough evidence to
make them believe it so you know when
you're watching one of the old movies
when they were just nobody was dealing
with production value the way we do now
you know it just takes a little bit to
make you believe in the story even if
the acting is bad right even if the set
is laughable but you still are in the
story if the story is good you know if
if the characters are good and the
dialogue is good and that's one of the
things that we try to instill in writers
is learn the mechanics of it because
it's easier then then you make it you're
not having to recreate a whole world
your you need to do the right strokes to
make the painting look like a person and
that's what we try to do and you know
the treatment book
this this shows you what you know this
is what you're doing as you do it you've
you're writing little search sentences
and you're putting hyphens and then
you're drawing a line connecting them
all but then when you put it on the side
you can see the shape of your story and
you can see where it needs some
attention you know where that you know
there is all these peaks here but no
real valleys so it would be much more
dramatic if you drop some of the
intensity or you added less intense
scenes in here so that the rises would
be greater etc and you know it could be
that everything is just fine when you do
this and it looks really perfect but
most the time you'll discover that it's
not a rollercoaster ride which is what
you want you know your reader to go on
you want them to to be screening all the
time basically and then toward the end
you see the highest peak and then it
levels down
yeah and levels down although you know
today's storytelling world maybe this is
not the right way to end a story you
know it might be better to end on a
higher peak
so I do have a few moments in time and
byte moments in time I'm talking about
the first scene and the last scene so
we're gonna identify in the first scene
what a character wants and then we're
gonna have a next moment that identify
is what I call the point of no return
this is the big event that's gonna push
us into the main part of the story it's
the event that makes this movie this
movie everything else on here is
internal to the character the point of
no return is the one moment and it's
external to the character it's the one
thing that has to happen to them so so
we're talking about Groundhog Day right
so the the point of no return is when he
wakes up and discovers it's the same day
again right and it should feel like it's
this moment makes this movie this movie
without that scene you wouldn't have the
movie Groundhog Day right it's
absolutely essential so it's important
like a moment like that that's gonna
drive the rest of the story it's also
external you notice it wasn't the point
of no return is never somebody decides
to do something there's an element of
fate that is involved when we're looking
at the point of no return so of all the
elements it's the one thing that's
external that had to happen to him he
could have not had that happen it woke
it up and it was February 3rd and then
this movie wouldn't be this movie but
for whatever reason he woke up and it
was February 2nd all over again
that's outside of his control if we were
gonna look at the movie Tootsie
sometimes people say oh the point of no
return is when he goes to audition for
the part that's a choice right so the
point of no-return needs to be external
to the character so I would not identify
it as he goes to audition what and what
you want to identify is the moment
outside of his control so the part where
everything really changes is when so he
could have blown that audition and he
almost blows that audition he comes very
close to blowing it but the female
producer likes him right and at one
point she says I like him I like her
we're gonna hire and she leans over and
says you got the part I'm sending the
contract to your agent
that's the point of no-return that
because that moments outside of his
control right that would had nothing to
do with his choice he could have blown
that audition he almost did blow up that
audition but that's the moment boom now
or in the movie known as Tootsie what
another thing I like to think of a great
example of this is the differences but
going from act 1 and act 2 is the Wizard
of Oz Wizard of Oz act 1 it's a black
and white point of no return is she
thinks that a tornado has lifted her
house up and dumped her in and Land of
Oz and boom weren't Technicolor we want
that feeling when we enter act 2
we're in a whole new world wait in
Kansas anymore right so it's a whole new
world there's facing it's one thing
Michael Dorsey decides to audition one
day as a woman it's another thing he's
got to fool everybody 24/7 into thinking
he's a woman that's the main story or in
Groundhog Day
he's now trapped in a cycle where every
day is grandma day that's the main part
of the story so they're two kinds of
stories I talk about in the book comedy
and tragedy and these are not these
definitions don't come from Joe blame me
if you don't like them they're from
Aristotle these are the original
academic different definitions of comedy
and tragedy so when I say comedy I'm not
talking about a haha comedy I'm talking
about an Aristotelian comedy and so no
Aristotelian comedy according to
Aristotle by definition is where we have
a protagonist who overcomes a flaw so
flaw is gonna be the next element I'm
going to talk about and that there
they're going to go through change and
then eventually they're going to have a
happy ending structurally we also have
tragedies a tragedy is going to be the
opposite so we have the same set up we
have the character wants something they
get it in a point of no return but
instead of going down down down and then
coming up and having a happy ending
we're gonna go in the opposite direction
they're going to go up up up up before
they come down and have their sad ending
ninety-five percent of stories are gonna
be calm based by the way oh yeah at
least 95 percent the next important
thing to talk about when I talk about
the point of no return in the point of
no return the character gets something
they want they also get something they
don't want and that's going to be what I
call the cat
so give it you want but with the cash so
Michael Dorsey gets apart but he's gonna
have to dress up as a woman in Groundhog
Day
Phil Connors only has to spend 24 hours
in Punxsutawney that was just one but
the catch is it's actually gonna be the
same 24 hours done over and over again
so the catch is attached so it's a
problem we can't just give our character
what they want because that deflates
conflict so you're giving them something
that they want along with something they
don't want and the catch is also could
be said to be the perfect test of their
flaw so the flaw and you know Phil
Conners flaw is that he's a self centric
this is the that for the catch being
that he's going to stuck spending the
same same day over and over again it's
the perfect test of someone who is
that they're self-centered in a comedy
it's gonna end in a happy ending but
they're gonna go down down down down
before because you've got to hit rock
bottom before you can make a change so
it keep in mind in your typical ha ha
comedy and your typical ha ha comedy is
an Aristotelian comedy it's down down
down now we're laughing as bad things
are happening to the protagonists they
are not laughing they're not having a
good time in act 2 of a comedy so that
are going to go down down now until
they're gonna hit rock bottom what I
call their crisis the crisis has two
requirements one is it's their absolute
lowest place and then it is the other
requirement is that the opposite of the
want actually Groundhog Day has a really
interesting one in that he's actually
finally spent after being stuck there he
finally tells the truth to read of the
love interest about what's going on and
they actually have kind of a wonderful
day together but it ends in this very
bittersweet moment where they're falling
asleep and he's says and the terrible
worst part is tomorrow you're gonna
think I'm a jerk again
and what is wonderful about it is this
wonderful irony and that's what we're
setting up with the crisis being the
opposite this irony he only wanted to
spend 24 hours and pucks of time
now he wishes the day could last forever
because tomorrow she'll think he's a
jerk again
so we're sending this delicious irony
there then the next thing we're going to
identify in the nutshell is we're now
entering the back three the beginning of
act 3 is the climax of your movie and
the operative word that we're going to
use though is the climatic choice at the
heart of a true climax your protagonist
is making a difficult decision
so in Groundhog Day his choice is to
start stop to stop fighting it to accept
that he's there and start trying to live
every day for the fullest and so he
becomes a really good person he starts
you know doing nice things and saving
the day and doing thinking of others
because what's the point in living and
trying to have short-term gratitude he's
got to find a different experiment with
a different way of living so he actually
starts becoming this town hero of this
person who's that known as this good guy
because he's got nothing better to do
and then finally break some free of the
curse and in the final step the final
step is the very last structural element
timewise the very last scene in the
movie
and now the characters gonna come to
full circle so if his flaw was that he
was self-centered he's come full circle
to its opposite strength that he now is
selfless and right because he's been
doing these things for everybody in the
town of Punxsutawney and he wakes up
that final day and he's actually it's
become February 3rd he's free of the
curse and he actually wants to stay so
those are the 8 structural elements and
so like I said it's not just moments in
time this is not a beat sheet method
they are what's important is the glue
it's the structure that holds these
pieces apart it's the connection between
these parts these are not isolated
moments in time we can see right on the
piece of paper what's working what's not
and if it's not working how to adjust it
by seeing that it fits you know what
what do we need to change in order to me
the requirements in order to tell a
story effectively
it originates in Hollywood history by
the accident of the one real film 35
millimeter film that became standardized
by the first decade of the 20th century
the first movies by that by that time
let's say that by 1910 there are single
real experiences there are 10 minutes
long and for various reasons in the
teens of Hollywood split in two
directions from the single real film to
what we call full-length features multi
real films hour and after two hours
three hours and in the other direction
to the serial which is a real or two
installments series and the reason you
have the origin of sequences is that in
the u.s. the distribution system was so
rigorously one real a week or two reels
a week that when they started to
generate full-length feature films they
were still distributed a couple of reels
a week so if you look at manuals of the
time it's been writing manuals they're
about 60 titles that came out in the
19-teens on how to write a photo play
because the market was kind of wide open
and people wanted to write these things
you'll get instructions about making
sure that each reel has a climax to it
so that the audience will be interested
in seeing the next reel and then they'll
see the next one after that so it was
almost like a limited series the feature
film by the late teens we are seeing
them all the distribution system is
changing and you're seeing in theaters
what we would normally experience as a
feat full-length feature but the the
idea of writing by the reels survived
into the 20s and 30s and you can see the
scene evidence of it in the way the
continuity scripts are marked they're
often marked by sequence letter sequence
ABCD and that is where
what we call sequences come the
nomenclature comes from what Frank
Danielle discovered in teaching in the
80s he discussed the three-act structure
in terms of setting up a situation
developing it and then paying it off but
he found that the students struggled
with the middle part of the script
because it's intimidating how do you
fill up 60 pages in the middle and
usually 30 pages to set it up 60 pages
in the middle and 30 pages in the third
act so he revived this idea of sequences
and he said well don't think of it in
terms of one you know act of 60 pages
think of it as four 15-minute scripts
that each one builds on the last and so
thus that the sequence approach is born
you're not gonna try to tackle a whole
120 pages just figure out these 15
minutes the first one first 15 minutes
and then the next 15 minutes then that's
gonna really do some kind of major
problem for a character so then they're
gonna try to explore the next for the
next 15 minutes and the the effect is
actually very liberating because you
wind up not worrying about how you're
gonna fill up these pages but more about
how you're gonna trim them down because
now you've got all this material but it
also helps you explore a premise really
fully you have a character let's just
take a classic dramatic construction
character wants something and there's
obstacles okay if they under the first
act they we know what they want we know
what the obstacles are going to be well
what is a character gonna do character
doesn't know what the movies about
character just thinks oh this is this is
easy I can solve this so they try
something and that's in your
conceptualization of the story the
character tries the easiest thing that
they can try and then the filmmaker the
screenwriter comes up with an obstacle
why that doesn't work that's maybe 10 15
minutes all right so now they got to try
something else
what's that gonna be and you can develop
it and each sequence has its own
integrity ideally the the paradigm
is that each sequence is going to have
three acts also it's gonna have some
kind of setup you don't have to do as
much setup because we know the
characters but you're gonna have to
introduce new circumstances they're
gonna try to get something and then it's
gonna end with some kind of resolution
usually negative because it's positive
maybe the movies over but it leads to
the next sequence and to the next one
and so you wind up with actually a kind
of a nested structure because the scenes
dramatic scenes have the same three acts
that's why I tend to like three acts you
can depends on how you define it but if
you understand it as working with
tension which tension is just putting
something in the audience's mind hope
and fear the character wants something
are they going to get it or not
that's what I'm wondering about and if I
care about the character then I'm gonna
stay tuned because I want to see the
answer to that so it's you don't need
more than three acts for that you just
need to set that up and then you need to
develop it and then you get the answer
so each act the act set up the whole
thing
then each sequence has its own ok
character wants something and there's
problems and then each scene has a
character that wants something in
there's obstacles so it's like this
iterative structure that keeps the
audience involved because we're
constantly wondering about what how it's
going to come out for the character and
one thing that we also recover in the in
the book down science of screenwriting
is this this process of connection to a
main character and what the theories are
about why we have that and it's
certainly important if you come into a
if you're at a park and you come in up
on a tennis game and two people are
really battling each other it may be
interesting but it's not gonna be
dramatic to you cause you don't know
them but if if you do know one if you
love one of them and you know that they
just mortgage their house and put
everything on this game and then you
know the other person is a hustler then
every my god you
something transformational but you have
to make that connection emotionally and
so so to get back about the sequence
structure you have many versions of the
new three acts and sequences and then in
the scenes and that is the suspense the
tension that keeps us interesting and we
also we have a chapter on the contrasts
in film and that plays also into this
approach which is that in order to
maintain audience attention the stimulus
has to be changed frequently otherwise
you you zone out you you'll lose
connection you will you'll think about
other things and you need to reset the
audience's brain periodically and
filmmakers do it you can see evidence of
it and changing light and dark loud and
soft fast and slow but you also see it
in tension and release tension
maintained for too long it's tedious but
if you release it and give us a chance
to reset then you can go on and build it
up again and again and again until you
reach the the culmination of the picture
and then finally you try to release it
entirely and and then people get people
to say yeah I want to see that movie
again I'm gonna tell my friends I want
to see it
generally what I'll do is I'll start
with the premise line I'll write out a
premise line sort of basically for me
like the foundation of the script a
couple of sentences take take you know
let's start to finish and then I'll
expand that into nine or maybe two three
four pages those sort of write it in
sections so I'll divide it in two into
three basically if it's a movie three
movie acts but you know a more in
quarters so it's like the equivalent of
a quarter quarter quarter quarter which
takes me through the four quarters or
the three acts of the of the movie so
it's I can keep it because one of the
things that happens when you start
writing it for me and when I start
writing out and at writing an outline in
you know prose form is that you know if
you don't if you don't from me if I
don't kind of stop you know stop writing
at a certain point you know you end up
with let's say your outline is for page
you're writing it just outlining it four
pages the first two pages may really
only be the first quarter of your script
because you know you you know you end up
writing so much and then then you have
to really then ultimately you end up
with kind of you know disproportionate
disproportionate acts so basically I'm
just trying to write it as tightly as I
can y'all write it long and then I'll
then I'll edit it but in the end I want
to end up with kind of four relatively
close descriptions of each quarter okay
so let's say that's that ends up being
three four pages whatever then if it's
on if it's an assignment then I'll then
I'll give it to the executive or
whatever I'll get notes on it rework it
and then if it's not for me I'll do the
same thing for myself and then what I do
is I divide the and this was a you know
really I have to credit writers boot
camp for this because they're really
this was kind of the way they taught me
how to do it and how I always do it now
and I taught other people and I I think
it's pretty I mean it's it's one of
those things that's just sort of like I
don't think it's on uncommon way to do
it but it kind of boils it down to I
think a really effective way of doing it
is that you divide I divide it up into
12 sequences three sequences in the
first act
six and the second act and three in the
third act of equal weight so basically
you know if you're writing 120 page
script or you know it's ten page as a
sequence if you're right
you're more like 100 page script it's
eight or nine pages of sequence and I
beat out the list of scenes so I'll take
a right turn I create a sequence
sentence you know so this is sequence
one two and three so out of that
sequence sentence that I write right out
pulled from the outline the longer
outline I then write a list of the
scenes that will comprise that that that
that's sequence so I'll put like with
the scenes in a row and then I'll figure
out how many pages that scene will
approximately be so that I can add it up
add up each sequence and say at the end
those six scenes will equal eight and a
half pages or something and it's an
estimate it may sometimes I'm very off
but it's an estimate and this is just my
kind of organized way of doing it you
know and and how I don't get lost in the
process you know and how I really kind
of stay on track this is just mine
everybody has the way of doing it and so
I do that so ultimately you end up with
basically twelve series of single
obscene lists so at which should eat
ultimately when you add it all up should
equal you know whatever your page desire
page count is one hundred one hundred
and five pages under twenty pages an
estimate and then I take that I put that
on to my final draft that lists on to my
final draft and I create a slug line
over each one
you know interior living room night
exterior you know baseball field date
whatever and and so I have the line and
then I you know the what the what the
scene is about and then I had the slug
line so basically what I end up with is
a whole written script except with that
dialogue essentially and then you go in
and just you know you craft it and to me
it's just it's a very step-by-step
process so it's like an accordion you're
constantly expanding that accordion
until you have the whole script written
so that that that works for me but
everybody does differently
template that's followed by most
commercial films and it breaks a story a
film narrative into four acts act 1 act
2 a act to be and act 3 and it contains
four major story engines that drive each
one of the individual acts and eight to
twelve major signpost plot beats it's
not deciding what you will write it's
providing a form and a template with
which the writer pours their story into
so a writer still makes their own unique
creative decisions but they may want to
think about what page ranges those
decisions fall in and the kind of basic
beats that would inform the storytelling
okay where do you think many new writers
go wrong in terms of the map in terms of
the layout what where most new writers
weak in that structure often it's over
writing to the point where those beats
are falling too late like I mentioned
the inciting incident should probably be
between 8 8 to page 8 to 12 but we also
want something that I call the strong
movement forward
the next major beat to be in the page 18
to 20 range sometimes that doesn't
happen until 28 and then the true end of
act 1 which should be around page 30 is
in the beginner script not happening
until page 38 and that really makes the
reader anxious and it slows down the
pace of the story and the structure so
it's not hitting the proper page ranges
again this isn't deciding what you
should write but it's deciding basically
what page range is the major beats
should be how you should tell the story
to some extent okay kind of that outer
frame of the story with which you're
pouring your uni unique decisions into
but as far as mistakes there's a major
signpost beet falling too early too late
or just not being there for example
there's a beet that I call the
assumption of power or declaration of
war beat and this should happen around
page 75 and you can see it in movies
that happens around minute 75 if that's
not there if there's not that moment
where this character really feels their
true power and acts in a way that makes
them rise to the occasion in kind of a
declaration of war or an attack and a
declaration of intent and something that
taps their inner strength if that's not
happening in that page range I don't
think the story is necessarily moving as
it should so a classic example would be
in the Karate Kid the show-me paint
house moment show me paint the fence
show me Sand the floor and it's that
moment at which Daniel Larusso realizes
he's been learning karate all along even
though mr. Miyagi
has been making him do all his chores so
he asked him to show him the the
positions that he's put his hands as
he's been doing these chores and it
turns out he's been learning karate this
whole time so he really Daniel really
realizes his true power realizes he can
do karate and he's doing it already you
want every scene to advance the story to
explore the controlling theme or reveal
crucial character okay it has to advance
the story so definitely that first one
it has to do in some way and then
ideally it will also be on theme that
major theme that central theme that this
particular story is exploring and then
third does it reveal some crucial
character you know something that we
haven't seen before about this
particular character I think it is you
know I think structure is very important
in hitting those page points is
important if for no other reason because
every reader in Hollywood has
internalized that structure but I mean
the real proof in the pudding is that
when you read pro scripts buy produced
writers by the top writers in Hollywood
who are making the top money they use
this structure so there has to be
something about it that is the reason
why the first act of a movie
is around 30 minutes there's something
there there's some reason why that works
I've worked with clients as a coach you
know consultant and help people do this
and help guide them through the process
but I also do it myself as a writer and
I do think that the save the cat book
and its tools are helpful I mean I my
favorite thing about saving the cat
really are the 10 genres and working
with and they each have like 5 sub
genres each that he goes into in the
second save the cat book save the cat
goes to the movies those genres I think
are super helpful and very original and
revolutionary for writers coming up with
ideas for a movie so I highly recommend
those but he also has the beach heat
which is the thing that saved the cats
most known for which is the 15 point
structural paradigm which I think was
Blake Snyder building on other paradigms
people had for 3x structure going back
to probably Aristotle but certainly Syd
field and other people's sense that and
I think he came up with some really good
ideas for here's what the first half of
act two of a movie usually looks like
any but the second half of back to
usually looks like and here's what the
second half of act 1 tends to look like
let me came up with fun names for these
different structural beats or sections
in a movie so I think that is a helpful
tool some people don't like it and you
know or have a love/hate relationship
with trying to like fulfill especially
when it's like it has to happen on this
page or that page which I'm not super
strict about but but I do think he had
some pretty good arguments for why he
felt this is a good page Langer this is
a good place in the movie for certain
things to happen so anyway when you do
up one of those beats sheets it ends up
being like a four-page document I think
ideally we're so what that means is
you're not spelling out every single
scene you're not figuring out every
single thing that happens in your movie
yet because that would take 10 or 15
pages there's no way to really do that
in 4 pages if you're trying to do that
in 4 pages and I've seen people do it
often with the note they're gonna get
back is this isn't enough for a movie
there's not enough scenes here it's not
enough that it's happening for this to
fill two hours so it's really about kind
of summarizing the key sections of the
movie and then the key points like the
midpoint and the breaking neck - and the
Brainiac 3 which are just moments you
know you kind of figure out what those
moments are and then you summarize the
sections in between so you kind of have
an overview of the structure so that was
one of Blake's Lake Snyder's big
contributions the
and I and I think it's helpful so I I
will use that as one method for kind of
working toward a structure I think there
is some truth to that that people are a
lot of times saying the same things in
different books and different paradigms
for story and screenwriting but I also
think people do come at it differently
and sometimes have different conclusions
about you know some of the precepts that
they come up with I mean like for
instance the dramatical theory of story
which I've played with a lot over the
years has a pretty different and
specific take on how stories work
compared to you know save the cat and
like the hero's journey the Christopher
Vogel book that is my understanding is
that's a certain kind of story he's
talking about which is a hero's journey
type story which not every story is a
hero's journey type story but if you're
writing that that book really goes into
kind of what the the structural points
tend to be in those kind of stories and
but yeah I do think to a large extent
people are speaking about the same
things like most people agree that like
the end of act 2 of a movie about 3/4 of
the way through there's usually a major
defeat crisis all is lost moment and
then there's a one last kind of chance
in the third act to solve whatever the
main kind of problem of that story was
and they might call it different things
but they kind of are talking about the
same thing
the first speeches I ever wrote for or
for TEDx Orange Coast I wrote eight of
them and I was like what I'm doing you
know I know how to tell a story but I
didn't really know how do you get the
person's life from point A to point B to
the end right and so I would get halfway
through the script and by the way I'd
turn around a lot of the scripts in two
to three weeks eight of them Wow so I
didn't have much time and I was working
seven days a week and like a I'm gonna
figure this out oh my goodness right and
so the rules were
I was anti rule really and then one day
I was working on it on a speech for this
TED talk one of them and I wanted to do
this woman justice I just adored her her
name is Amy Purdy and she and I were
collaborating together and I just
thought I've got to do this justice what
how do I tell a story you know we were
in there we were doing stuff but it just
wasn't hitting the mark and so I said
okay Google let's locate magic 8-ball
let me just show it and see what comes
back and I just typed in story arc and
all of a sudden I clicked on images and
I saw something called the hero's
journey I was like you know what I feel
like I've heard about that before what
is this crazy thing called the hero's
journey and I looked at the visual it's
a beautiful visual somebody taken their
time to really show me all the steps and
I was like wait this is how I this is
how this works I can do this this is
exactly what I need Amy had eight
minutes TED talks are off in 18 minutes
but she only had eight minutes that's
what they gave her and some of my other
speakers had 12 minutes and you know
which four minutes is a huge difference
let me tell you eight is tight and so I
was like I can do this I can cross the
threshold with her story this is
wonderful and we did it and her talk
went viral and so this was back in 2011
and it was affirmation for me and I was
like I don't know these Hollywood people
this way but I love them and so then I
started following that for certain
people I started using the hero's
journey and because there are their
emotional beats in there and I noticed
that my speeches were following those
beats I would just look over I'd be like
is this going the way it is I would find
it I would just mirror them and they
could almost cross math and what was
beautiful about that is that the the
people I tend to work with the speakers
I tend to work with and especially now
now that I've been doing this a long
time I'm really I really want beauty out
in the world and I want my speakers to
disseminate that that beauty which I
already have in them right and the
hero's journey really does that because
the audience doesn't hear the speaker
they hear what the speaker has been
through but they only think about
themselves and what they've been through
in relation to what that speaker has
been through so you know speakers will
be like I don't know if I could say that
and I'm like it's not about you the
audience is gonna say oh my god - you
know or my mother went through that or
someone I knew or you know and they they
start to they hear your story but in
relationship to themselves and so that
that hero's journey has been incredibly
important in in in the storytelling
process
it has to deliver the dramatic question
you know ideally there is a protagonist
who has a very clear objective ideally
there are stakes so there are
consequences if that protagonist doesn't
succeed and the higher the stakes the
more dramatic the story
ideally there is a scene and there's a
whole book save the cat but it's kind of
based on that ideally you have given the
audience a reason to side with that
protagonist which a lot of movies and
scripts leave out completely which is
amazing to me because it's one of the
main ingredients why would I as an
audience care if that character sees his
father before he dies you know there
must be something that shows me a
humanity inside of that character it can
be a bad bad mafia serial killer
whatever guy but something that I can
relate to where we share our humanity in
that moment so that he becomes the
vehicle for me to discover things about
myself in the end I think that's the
secret that every audience it's a very
that's a very selfish process I think
every audience really comes to the
theater to learn something about
themselves and not about Oklahoma or
space or whatever but about their
emotions in that moment but that only
works if you can create a connection
between the protagonist and the audience
earlier so that would probably be the
formula of looking for is there a
connection is there a clear want which
leads to the dramatic question which is
will this protagonist successfully save
the love of his life whatever whatever
and then you go into the second act
where there are where you have to look
at the conflicts is there enough he is
what he steps he is doing are they
escalating in a way that at the same
time is believable but also doesn't need
too much patience because in real life
you would probably first phone his
grandmother and then
he would go then we don't want to sit
through all that we want the condensed
version we want the fake version but we
wanted to feel emotionally real which is
a hard thing to achieve but it was
something that you can very clearly
track throughout a second action I think
and the first half of the second act
normally traditionally is called like
the fun and games part which is where
most the see of the scenes that you see
in a trailer are in the first half of
the second act where the promise of the
movie the reason why people came is to
see those scenes you know it's like oh
there's a man that talks to his snake
melt Mel Gibson with this beaver and
Jodie Foster's movie you know that would
be the first half of the second act
where we kind of have a little bit of
time the clock isn't taking quite as
fast yet and then most of the time the
mid-point halfway through the story is a
more fundamental twist to the whole
story it turns out the beaver is real or
it has whatever whatever you know can
actually talk of something that changes
our whole look on the story in the
direction of the story which i think is
super important because otherwise the
second act gets very long like if it's
only a one directional thing which
exists of course it exists successfully
but it's very hard to execute to keep
the audience's attention without
something that in the middle kind of
breaks the movie up and gives it a whole
different direction and a lot of time
like in a spy movie it would be our
protagonist finds out that the agency he
is working for is actually the bad guys
volatile so 70 is or in Mad Max it's
when they've been driving into that one
direction and now they have a chief
whatever they need to achieve another
literally turning around coming back
that would be kind of the midpoint then
the stakes have to be raised in the
second half of the second act and lead
to the major confrontation then if you
go by the hero's journey which I believe
in a lot Joseph Campbell and all that
kind of stuff
there is the major confrontation it
looks like the hero is going to die he
metaphorically dies sheds his old ego
learned something about himself that he
didn't know before there's most of the
time painful and that enables him
because he doesn't break at that moment
he almost breaks you get him to the
breaking point
and you can see that in almost every
movie that that is being done because we
need to really break a character to see
what he's made of right if you never
challenge a character you don't know
what he really has inside of so you
almost break him and in that process of
staring death in the face metaphorically
or the office in a romantic comedy it
would be the girl is dating another guy
you know it doesn't have to be death
literally but it's the death of that so
now our protagonist learns something
about himself that was in his flights
but that he didn't know before which now
enables him to be to use that as a tool
to change
that's why character arcs and
development are so important become a
different person and that enables him to
achieve the goal that he hadn't been
able to achieve before nowhere in the
third act where most of the time he has
to defend where he's where he is
challenged by the antagonistic force
that he's been battling throughout the
second act one last time and that's
where the big dragon or Sauron or
whatever we know rears his head for the
first time a text and that he has to
prove that the change that he just went
through is a permanent one that can be
challenged and he won and will still
survive with his old ego end of story
so there will be at least the there's
been a thaller G that thousands of years
old
you know paradigm that stories are
building you can go away from that
paradigm as much as you want but I think
it helps to know that that is what
audiences intuitively are expecting and
someone who does that really great is
Tarantino like I don't think there's
anyone who knows this story structure
better and messes with it and messes
with your expectation which is great but
it's different from not knowing it and
just writing something into the blue and
then wondering why people don't I
follow the characters or aren't hooked
to certain development or something like
that so that would be my my formulas
structure that I can if I'm if I'm
reading it and I'm engrossed then it
doesn't matter you know if it's a
three-act structure or whatever but if I
feel like my attention kind of drifts
and I don't really care most of the time
the answer is in that structure that
somehow it doesn't deliver what it needs
to deliver
some rating teachers say the three-act
structure is dead it's it's it's
remedial its it it's it's not going to
it's it's going to kill any creativity
and the problem with that is that they
don't understand what the three-act
structure is because the three-act
structure is has nothing to do with
plotting in my opinion and unfortunately
the a lot of story structure is taught
by story analysts who are sort of
brilliant left brain left brain errs and
are really adept at deconstructing a
masterpiece and and sort of the
implication is that now that we've
deconstructed this you should go off and
write your masterpiece and while there's
tremendous amount of value in in in
studying film theory or you know film
theory because it's that that's that's
you know deconstructing Casablanca or
Citizen Kane is is going to help you
understand how a story was built some
degree but it's not going to teach you
process it's not going to teach you how
to organize your ideas when you look at
a movie like Casablanca and you think
about the Epstein brothers writing you
know we're structuring this this movie
they I'm interested in in the process
I'm interested in how did somebody come
to write this in other words you can you
can sort of like just because you
deconstruct something you so it's like
vivisection you can't you can't take
something dead and look at all of its
existing parts and then and then
reanimate it it's not going to come back
to life and so just because you can
break down this thing into its it's sort
of separate parts doesn't mean you're
going to uncover the mystery of what the
thing actually
is in other words story structure is
really the DNA of your protagonists
transformation that makes sense the
story centers the DNA of a protagonist
transformation it's not you know in the
midpoint there should be a reversal like
I don't even know what that means you
hear it all the time with with these
story analysts that should be reversible
what the hell does you know does does
It's a Wonderful Life have a reversal
that's where mr. Potter offers Jimmy
Stewart a job and Jimmy Stewart says no
I don't know I I don't I think of I
think of story structure as not a
conceptual model something we can figure
out but it's it's more of a experiential
model in other words your protagonist
goes through a series of experiences
that lead to a transformation and I
think if story structure as an immutable
paradigm for a spiritual transformation
okay it's immutable it never changes but
that doesn't make it that doesn't that
doesn't limit your creativity that
actually paradoxically opens your
creativity in other words when when you
really understand what story structure
is it moves you beyond your limited
imagination of what your story is I
always tell my writers your idea of your
story is not the whole story it's not
that it's incorrect it's that it's
incomplete and so if you were to distill
story structure to three words it would
be desire surrender transformation so
show me any story there's you're gonna
have a character that wants something
desire you're gonna have a character
that lets go of the meaning they made
out of their goal surrender you're gonna
have a character that experiences
transformation in other words a shift in
perception a reframing of their
relationship to their goal
show me a story that doesn't have that
and I'll show you a story that doesn't
work you know or is really experimental